because this opened just a few years
after Gray's Anatomy premiered do you
feel like having that TV doctor
background sort of inspired this then in
a way I don't think consciously at first
but I think it was it allowed people to
look at me in a different way yeah and
then you have to step up and become that
person and it's made me a better person
because of that and I think also too
it's been on the show I think it's been
on for like 15 years which was
remarkable and they're beginning their
season right now and I wish them a lot
of luck and continued success and I see
people from around the world have that
have now were inspired to become doctors
and younger people who are now just
discovering the show who want to go into
the medical profession I think the
greatest legacy with everybody x-rays it
was a remarkable experience and without
that success this wouldn't be possible
so I thank them for that Patrick Dempsey
has nothing beloved for Grey's Anatomy
he left the show in 2015 but during our
exclusive chat this week he couldn't
help but praise former co-star Ellen
Pompeo so picked me choose me
love me it sounds like there's so much
love still for you and the Grays cast
Ellen Page you the biggest compliment
saying that you are a tough act to
follow and that's why her character has
had a hard time finding love how do you
respond to that well that's yeah I mean
it's um I think the success of this ship
that's a wonderful compliment and thank
you and I that was a very special bond
that there was just there was a magic to
our connection and that's special and I
think it started with the original cast
and the length that it has and there are
new people that come in and you know
it's amazing that it's continuing to
affect so many people it's a really a
strong part of so many people's lives
and you're part of a television history
you know it's these days Patrick is
still acting but really enjoys being
behind the camera and he's producing the
upcoming Milo Ventimiglia flick the art
of racing in the rain I had so much time
in front of the camera with Grey's
Anatomy I'm enjoying the producing and
it's nice to to be watching Milo on his
ascent in the success of that show there
are a lot of parallels he night both
leading men and he gives credit to
Grey's for preparing him I learned a lot
through my experience on Grey's about
what an actor needs and what what it's
like after 10 years and you're seeing a
lot of the cast members who are
directing now and they always make the
best directors like Kevin Chandra and
all this and I think Ellen's directing
now too which is I think really good
Dempsey is also growing the Dempsey
Center the cancer treatment facility he
opened in 2008 has it changed your
perspective in what you do on a day to
day basis
Hollywood wise oh absolutely yeah yes
and how you and who you work with and
why you work with them it's a gut-check
sure you know and and you also need to
continue to grow and to stretch and
that's true for us in our programs and
and for the people that come through
emotional wellness physical wellness all
those things are at play here and these
are the big issues that are important in
life
giving back compassion love
understanding and empathy sometimes we
we lose that in the world where we're in
there with so much partisanship
[Music]
[Applause]